[Music]
look this book is an all-new superman
this is not something
that happens every day this is a
superman number one this is a new
character stepping into the role of
superman
in a way that hasn't been done before
stepping in to to do big things he gets
arrested for standing up at a rally for
refugees he fights things in a way that
isn't always with his fists he doesn't
see
borders as the end of
or the reason to stop doing good
so i think the key differences between
jonathan and club obviously part of it
is the age you know i have a 15 year old
son and
i see what he's passionate about and how
passionate he is about that and i think
john is very much that he sees the
problems with the world just like just
like clark does but he sees it on a
different level he sees things like
climate change he sees inequality and
equity and he wants to do something
about it
[Music]
he is a really really empathetic person
and so
when he sees that when he sees this
person on fire in the forest with the
military attacking him with
with the world exploding around him he
doesn't instantly look
to fight that he looks at this character
and sees the anxiety
and
despite being you know just because
you're the most powerful person on earth
doesn't mean
that you have to use your power for
fighting for punching for
you know for violence and jonathan will
constantly look for
another way to do that and so i think
him stepping into there
and hugging him and telling him he's
gonna be okay and that he's got it
um is just as powerful as anything he
could have done physically
[Music]
absolutely yeah it's um i think i think
whenever i'm writing this i'm writing it
with my particularly with my eldest son
in mind you know the the conversations
that he and i have especially haven't
been in lockdown for 200 days or more
here in melbourne we have big
conversations about
various forms of injustice
and the things that he wishes were right
with the world
and so you do see some of the
conversations like john's just had on
the moon with clark um about what he
sees in the world as you know as a as a
person who can see the macro and the
micro um he has x-ray vision he has
telescopic vision he can see
the oceans rising he can see ice
receding you know he wants to do
something and i think my son is the same
i think more than anything there's
there's a really healthy respect between
bruce and clark and where they're kind
of concerned about
annoying one another damian and john
don't have that they will rib each other
constantly they will constantly tell
each other how they can be better or
what they're doing wrong i think also
the two of them growing up they have a
relationship that is very brotherly they
can speak the truth to each other and in
a way they they can also look after each
other
[Music]
i think it's for a lot of reasons i've
said for you know from the very first
comic i ever wrote i've said
that everybody needs heroes and
everybody deserves to see themselves in
their hero um
and superman's no different when it came
time for peop for dc when they asked me
they said do you know would you be
interested
in writing john kemp as superman i mean
they knew that writing superman has been
my dream forever but if i was doing that
i needed to work out why
what's the reason to write
this character and what i came to
realize was there wasn't a point in
having another straight white savior
come in and be superman there had to be
something
more people that he represented and i
think john you know finding himself in
this way as he does in these upcoming
issues and the conversations we're going
to have there are really important for a
lot of people
[Music]
[Music]
you